اخر سؤال اخر سؤال هادو هادشي
[موسيقى]
بيترو تسوين
كسرنا عينه ايوه ايوه
كسرنا عينه كوكاكو
[موسيقى]
في راسنا بزاف وديمه المغرب وفي الاخير
ربحنا
لاول مره من 1998 المنتخب المغربي يحقق
فوز في كاس العالم ما هو الشعور اليوم
شكرا اخوان الناس ديال قطر على حسن
الضيافه فاذا كانت قطر نجحت في تنظيم
فالمغرب نجح اليوم بوضع خطوه الاولى
بالتاهل الى الدور القادم فالمقابله اليوم
كما قالوا الاخوان كان تاكتيكيه فكانت
تغييرات اللي قام بها مدرب بها وليد
الركراكي هي اللي كانت تعطلت النتيجه
فالحمد لله هذه نتيجه نتيجه
الكره المغربيه وكذلك شرفت الدوله العربيه
فهم نتمنى ان شاء الله همم المقابله
الثالثه ضد مغربي
الاولى في الخطوه الثانيه هي انتصار على
كندا المجموعه
الثانيه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله فرحونا
بزاف المغاربه اليوم والله زعما فرحه
كبيره
وصراحه اللي يحضر اليوم الملعب زعما راه
حسب ذلك
وصراحه كان مغربيه انا همم كانحس بهذيك
حتى مغربي ديالي اليوم صراحه وان شاء الله
ههه معرفتش اشنو غادي نقول لك والله ان
شاء الله يفوز فريق المغربي
الامل همم
شكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا
عندي رجال تقاتلوه معنا كيف ما شفتوا
الجمهور ما سكتش دخلت معهم تقاتلو معنا
رجال شكرا بزاف وتلقاونا ان شاء الله في
المباراه ديال كندا واللي ترى اللي بغا
يطرح لديمه معكم
وديما مغرب
المجموعه صعبه ما كنا كانتسنا والو منها
منها ضروري
[تصفيق]
مبروك علينا
يا بابا
[تصفيق]
مجهود كبير
[موسيقى]